more like muscle puppets do I need the
rock Johnson eyelids of fun with Emily
blind on the set of their upcoming
Disney movie Jungle Cruise meanwhile
Emily's husband John Krasinski is
governor Cruz but rather on a battleship
and we caught up with him at his math
lab Jack Ryan premiere they shut down a
battleship put up a giant 22 foot tall
movie screen and still all we could look
at was hot mr. Krasinski yep that's
right hot and here's your proof yes we
binge watched all eight episodes of
Amazon's Jack Ryan to find John's best
shirtless shots and one very sexy
makeout scene and if you're ever
wondering how John compares to Ben
Affleck Harrison Ford Chris Pine and
Alec Baldwin all who have played the CIA
super spy in the past well we asked I
don't even know who you're talking about
I was told it was the first no I did
I've emailed back and forth very nicely
with Alec Baldwin who's a friend and a
supporter of everything I do but
certainly this was a fun irony to be
talking about the same part I'm the best
chance you have you can't grow up to be
Iron Man but to grow up to be some sort
of person who uses their brain and their
instincts and puts their life on the
line for other people selflessly is
something you can do John's co-stars
Windell Pierce you probably know him
from suits and this seen walking Megan
Markel down the aisle but could we see
the Duchess in a future Jack Ryan
storyline you never know no she doesn't
need saving right now you know she's
very happy and
happy for her season 2 of the show was
already in the works and so is a sequel
to John in Emily's 330 million dollar
sleeper hit of the year a quiet place
I've been tinkering with an idea for a
few months and it just started to
percolate and then we're all really
happy it's a great I don't give it away
don't go away
[Music]
[Applause]